not the only ones who saw severe weather  this week at least 25 people are dead  after flash floods left parts of  kentucky under water emergency workers  are scrambling to locate victims and  survivors there the storm knocked out  internet and cell phone service for many  while entire buildings like this were  ripped off their foundations and carried  away by the water  this is still an emergency situation we  are in search and rescue mode this hit  the entirety of the county  from one end to the other  it hit everything  in a span of 48 hours between wednesday  and friday up to 10 and a half inches of  rain fell in parts of eastern kentucky  most of the area's rivers were not  expected to crest until today now  they're bracing for even more wet  weather tomorrow